salut romain savak puisque tut tut werc
non je contrôle pas comment c'est
possible ça je me suis assis sur un truc
rouillé et donc je crois j'ai chopé le
tetanus le
vous avez peut-être un point commun avec
romain vous avez sans doute entendu dire
qu'on chope et le tétanos en se blessant
avec un objet rouillé et si ça se trouve
vous y avez cru normal pas de honte à ça
pas de jugement par contre c'est faux
pas comme ça que ça se passe
le tétanos est une maladie provoquée par
le clostridium tétanie ou bacille de
nicolas hier du nom du microbiologiste
allemand qui l'a isolé est décrit en
1884 le clostridium tétanie donc c'est
un bacille c'est à dire une bactérie de
forme allongée on dit en forme de
bâtonnet
même si en l'occurrence les
scientifiques parlent d'une forme de
raquette de tennis ou de baguettes de
batterie
manifestement c'est des scientifiques
qui sont pas très fort en tennis et qui
n'ont jamais joué de batterie et qui
n'ont jamais vu de ce fait à l'état de
sport c'est à dire sous sa forme
inactive y peut survivre très longtemps
si il est au chaud à l'abri de la
lumière dans un environnement humide
mais s'il pénètre dans le corps humain
il peut se réactiver et libérer sa
toxine et c'est là que ça commence à mal
se mettre sa toxine c'est la tétanos
passe mines et le problème c'est qu'elle
est neurotoxiques
c'est à dire qu'elle se fixe sur les
neurones a fini par atteindre le système
nerveux central et la fn 1 ce qui est
fait c'est qu'elle empêche la libération
de certains neurotransmetteurs c'est à
dire des substances chimiques qui
agissent sur les neurones et qui active
ou qui empêchent certaines fonctions de
l'organisme
là en l'occurrence la tétanos passe
mines est perturbé l'action des neurones
qui sont chargés de réguler les
contractions des muscles et résultat les
muscles se contractent ça peut aller
très vite
les symptômes peuvent apparaître entre 3
jours et trois semaines après la
contamination
mais en général c'est ou deux semaines
et les fameux symptômes au départ ça
peut être des spasmes ou des
contractures des muscles de la mâchoire
de la nuque du dos du ventre etc
attention on parle de muscles qui se
contracte brutalement et de façon
prolongée genre ça surprend ça dure ça
fait mal
dans la forme la plus grave du tétanos
est à dire si on fait rien c'est tous
les muscles qui se contracte en même
temps un peu comme si votre corps tu es
une immense crampes qui veut pas
s'arrêter
ça s'appelle un nos pistes autonome et
dans ces cas-là on décrit des malades
qui sont en arc de cercle et qui touche
le lit uniquement avec l'arrière du
crâne et les talons le problème comme on
l'a dit c'est que ça dure et le pire
c'est que la toxine elle peut atteindre
les muscles respiratoires et les
paralyser c'est même la principale cause
de décès liés au tétanos
oui parce que l'on peut en mourir on en
meurt dans 30% des cas à peu près en
france et 50% dans le monde si on est un
adulte parce que pour les nouveau-nés ça
monte à 70 voire 100%
d'ailleurs les premières victimes du
tétanos aujourd'hui c'est les nouveau
nés dans des pays où il n'ya pas de
vaccination et où les conditions
d'hygiène sont basses la porte d'entrée
c'est le cordon ombilical au moment où
on coupe à cause des instruments qu'on
utilise ou de ce qu'on met sur la plaie
en france par contre la maladie elle a
quasiment disparu depuis qu'on a
découvert un vaccin est qu'il est devenu
obligatoire en 1940 genre ya une dizaine
de cas par an chez des gens qui sont pas
ou plus couverts bon mais pour en
revenir à la question de départ
qu'est ce que la rouille vient faire là
dedans si on se fait un petit peu la
liste de ceux dont on a besoin pour
choper le tétanos on a des spores de
clostridium tétanie un endroit chaud
humide et à l'abri de la lumière pour
qu'ils puissent tranquillement attendre
le client un corps humain et une
blessure donc lé sport puisse entrer
dans le corps humain
bon les sports et le corps humain
maintenant on voit à peu près comment ça
se présente
mais la blessure déjà bas ça peut être
soit une blessure qu'on avait déjà et
les sports viennent se coller dedans
soit une blessure qu'on se fait sur le
moment dans l'environnement où l'espoir
se trouve et si ça se trouve même des
sports y en a sur l'objet qui nous
blessent bon et donc comme environnement
chaud humide et à l'abri de la lumière
qu'on peut être amené à fréquenter
qu'est ce qu'on a l'arche à ta grand
mère n'ont pas ça non il ya la terre par
exemple la terre alors je dis par
exemple mais en vrai c'est par un
exemple complètement au hasard parce que
il se trouve que dans la majorité des
cas c'est comme ça qu'on chope le
tétanos une plaie soulier
par de la terre et c'est là que la
rouille intervient admettons qu'on chope
le tétanos en se coupant avec un objet
en fer qui serait resté dans la terre un
petit moment avec l'humidité et tout
comment ils seraient cet objet en fer
que rester dans la terre un petit moment
avec l'humidité et tout bas il ferait
rouillé et comme c'était un cas de
figure assez fréquent à l'époque où on
chope est fréquemment le tétanos bas les
gens ils ont fait le raccourci entre la
rouille et le tétanos
mais en réalité n'importe quel objet qui
vous rentre dans la peau il peut faire
rentrer de clostridium tétanie avec lui
une écharde une épine de roses des
ronces n'importe quoi et puis le
clostridium tétanie on le trouve pas que
dans la terre en vrai peut trouver dans
plein d'endroits on peut trouver dans la
poussière dans des lieux un petit peu
sombre et un petit peu humide et aussi
dans le caca de certains animaux parce
que les sports il résiste à la digestion
donc rien à voir avec la rouille
oui roman pour montanus alors pendant
dix ans victoire qu'est j'étais surpris
la panique et à revendre et toute cette
histoire de tetanus on est d'accord
voilà à détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien